alors que la promotion de son nouveau
film j'accuse avec jean dujardin louis
garrel ou encore emmanuelle seigner qui
sort aujourd'hui battait son plein
romane polanski s'est retrouvé une
nouvelle fois au coeur d'une terrible
polémique
la comédienne française valentine
monnier accuse le réalisateur de l'avoir
violée lorsqu'elle avait 18 ans une
accusation que le réalisateur nie
farouchement et qui n'est pas assorti
d'une plainte puisque les faits présumés
se seraient déroulés en 1975 et sont
donc prescrits romane polanski est un
scénariste et réalisateur très reconnue
et saluée par la critique
à l'origine d'une quarantaine de films
dont plus de vingt longs métrages il a
remporté quatre césars et une palme d'or
et si cette affaire dérange quand c'est
parce que la vie privée du réalisateur
prodige est loin d'être aussi brillante
que sa carrière en 1977 aux états unis
il est poursuivi pour une sordide
affaire de viol d'une mineure qu'il
aurait d'abord drogué un feuilleton qui
quarante ans après n'est toujours pas
refermée le 10 mars 1977 roman polanski
alors âgé de 43 ans et déjà réalisateur
mondialement connu aurait eu une
relation sexuelle avec une mineure de 13
ans samantha geimer en marge d'une
séance de photographie à hollywood le 8
août de la même année il décide de
changer de stratégie et plaide coupable
pour détournement de mineur et lorsqu'il
apprend cinq mois plus tard qu'il risque
la peine maximale de prison c'est à dire
50 ans le réalisateur décide de fuir les
états unis et de s'installer à paris où
il est né en 1933 depuis il n'a jamais
remis un pied aux états unis ces
nouvelles accusations relance donc la
polémique le réalisateur est encore très
soutenue par le monde du cinéma qui
différencie l'homme de l'artiste mais de
nombreuses personnes pensent au
contraire qu'il faudrait tout simplement
boycotté son dernier film pour condamner
ces actes
alors selon vous faut-il aller voir le
nouveau film de roman polanski il va
gagner ce soir le oui non et oui alors
je vous le dis chaque soir ils se
demandent quelle équipe va gagner lors
du quart d'heure son fils tu sais vous
qu'elle est décidée faut-il aller voir
ou non le film de roman polanski
alors on est allé poser la question ce
matin devant un cinéma parisien pour
savoir si les spectateurs ont
l'intention de boycotter le film ou non
et dans un instant on aura les infos de
christophe carrière qui est passé ici
qui va nous dire si les chiffres sont
bons regardez vous allez voir le film de
roman polanski
oui bien sûr par rapport à cette
question et à la polémique qui s'en
suivit
une position qui est assez partagée
c'est pas terrible ce qui la fait
évidemment s'il s'avère que c'est vrai à
aller voir un film d'un réalisateur
c'est forcément soutenir le réalisateur
un peu comme ça me dérange un peu c'est
déstabilisant il ya des très bons
artistes qui sont des [ __ ] fini ça
n'a rien à voir avec avec ses talents
normalement il faudrait le boycotter ou
est peut-être qu'il faudrait le buzz
côté quand même alors qu'est ce que vous
en pensez vous vous pensez géraldine
maillet qui ne faut pas aller voir le
film de roman polanski j'ai plein de
d'image à vous montrer leur mois titre
personnel j'ai pas envie d'aller voir ce
film il faut quand même rappeler que
polanski a plaidé coupable d'avoir
drogué et sodomisé une jeune fille de 13
ans aux états unis qu'il a fait quelques
jours de prison et puis après il a fui
et que depuis il ya un mandat d'arrêt
américain
et que c'est pour ça qu'ils n'est que en
france et en pologne parce que sinon il
est extradé
jusqu'à présent mais je trouve que la
justice médiatique lui a donné raison la
extrêmement protégé il a été célébré par
clamé multi récompensé mais je trouve
qu'aujourd'hui c'est indécent depuis
adèle haenel qui a libéré la parole de
ma lentille monnier qui est donc la 10e
femme qui dit qu'elle a été violée alors
qu'elle était mineure par polanski
moi j'estime que c'est indécent j'estime
qu'on ne peut pas éternellement se
planquer derrière l'excusent artistes
versus l'homme moi excusez moi ça me
donne la nausée et je trouve qu'on l'a
suffisamment protégés que les
gouvernements français successifs l'ont
suffisamment protégé qu'il a la carte
même dit que je n'irai pas voir noir
désir j'ai pas envie d'aller voir le
contrat le film de rose bosch
d'autant plus que le propos du film est
extrêmement tendancieux va rappeler le
propos du film c'est déjà plus c'est la
fermeture jacques huard et savent
exactement dans cieux par rapport à 6
par rapport au message sus nominal et à
la propre histoire et ce qu'il veut bien
instrumentalisée dans ce livre on va pas
rentrer d'aliments
pourquoi là dans les deux écoles et les
féministes alors dossards ont fait le
déplacement pour assister à la
projection du film en présence des
acteurs et de robben polanski hier soir
mais aucun des invités n'a voulu
s'exprimer sur la polémique regarder sa
personnalité ont assisté ce soir à la
projection en avant première de ce film
j'accuse ces cas des acteurs pierre
richard et vincent perez ainsi de
l'actrice fanny ardant présent également
la journaliste anne sinclair et puis
aussi à l'ancien ministre jack lang mais
parmi ces personnalités et concernant
les accusations de viol ont fait l'objet
romane polanski est bien aucune de ces
personnalités qui ont assisté à la
projection ce soir n'a souhaité répondre
à nos questions sur la polémique alors
personne n'a voulu s'exprimer sauf une
star le pauvre c'est son bep sur mickey
news
le pauvre michael il était tranquille il
a accepté le pauvre lui de venir
s'exprimer
et derrière il s'est fait ces fonds
c'est le procès soit là c'est un mec que
j'aime pour offrir des soins de michael
c'est un super gars c'est un amour de
mecs quand je vois anne sinclair qui
sauverait il s'occupait à faire des
tweets sur moi voilà quand elle fait pas
des fuites sur moi elle va voir l'avant
première de romane polanski pas
apparemment allée voir l'avant première
de roman polanski salus à la choque moi
que ce qui se passe dans cette émission
mais bon voilà ça c'est autre chose elle
elle s'est barrée mais qu elle ou lui le
pauvre il a voulu parler voilà et orgue
avec ses collègues les plus gênés de
vous répondre je suis pas gêné d'être là
mais ce que je suis content d'aller voir
ce film ait su su j'aurais préféré
qu'ils pas de polémique
alors derrière le pauvre michael voilà
il s'est fait défoncer il est sérieux
michael où ils respect pour les victimes
de guy georget de polanski voilà alors
les impôts ville
je pense qu'il est tellement gentil
mickaël s'est jamais prononcée n'aime
pas ce qu'il allait dire et il s'est
fait un petit toit de la maison et du
jardin ne pas être amenés à terre
quand le coup j'aimerais y aller vous
pourquoi moi je vais devoir parce que de
l' affaire dreyfus m'a toujours
passionné
[Musique]
sa critique sinna man vient me donne
jamais non à les aimer parce que moi
j'appelle ou et parle pas du film avec
film4 oui je vais le voir parce que en
plus de monter d'antisémitisme je trouve
que c'est un film humain je souhaite que
polanski soit extradé pour répondre
devant la justice
mais moi je mets par un film j'ai
parfois lens qui dit jeu elle fait ce
qu'elle dirait la tribune elle les voit
isabelle sms
si le film intéresse isabelle arrive à
faire la distinction entre l'artiste et
l'homme elle a le droit et c'est son
droit il avait laissé la dire ce qu'elle
pense et laissez-la s'exprimer benjamin
castaldi
franchement j'aime les j'aime le cinéma
j'aime les acteurs j'aime ce qui fait
qu'ils font sur un plateau les costumes
et les maquillages et je trouve que pour
ces gens-là recruter un film c'est pas
bien après il ya une autre polémique sur
le monsieur sur le réacteur mais
honnêtement pour tous ceux qui ont fait
ce film pour les comédiens qui pourront
pas pu s'exprimer comme le défend le
film pour le propos du film
il faut les voir le film s'en foutent
les conneries excuse moi ces bouquets le
problème par rapport au film allemand le
fils de rosa il offrirait les vents le
film où trouver un deuxième souffle un
nom tout trouvé
on va parler aller voir le film c'est
dieu voilà un petit peu voilà c'est fait
ces niveaux-là ses manies des oliviers
pas validé ce carnet rose
c'est toi cathy vous que c'est pendant
ce qui s'est passé car oui ou non non
des gens qui oeuvrent tout un territoire
c'est le mélange de quelqu'un qu'on ne
cautionne pas les personnes là bas il a
rien à voir il polanski non plus aussi
un peu quand même mais bon voilà non
méchant et ces gens là on va pas tout de
boycotter un finish et le méchant de
dire cela l'histoire de j'accuse
m'intéresse mais bien l intéresse tout
le monde
il aurait produit boule et bill 3 c'est
ce que les mêmes problèmes de choisir un
côté à champions et parle à chaque fois
on ne peut pas laisser cette saisine de
ce match là et dire non même parti n'ont
ils pas polanski la violer il devrait
entendre ce mec là il est trop tôt alors
s'il vous plaît je suis pas content je
m'attends pas à laisser s'exprimer
wolinski l'a violée il a été condamné
d'accord il a été juge doit il a été
extradé il se cache
d'accord ouais ouais la france a les
complices de ça pourquoi les producteurs
de cinéma et son complice de ça parce
qu'il ya des gens médias sont complices
d'eau il devrait en taule il a violé
c'est prouvé moi je vais te dire comment
jouer et je m'élève mois moi je mets en
avant
on a vu tout élevé là des films comme ça
j'accuse en allant au théâtre en en
rencontrant des jamais connu l'argent en
rencontrant des gens comme vous qui
m'apprennent d'autre chose que ce que
j'ai connu des succès un village en leur
les voir si mou les bills si c'était
boule et bill
je repars avec toi red bull et
d'histoire géo à maclas moi c'est
vraiment toi tu vas les bons parce que
le sujet d'intérêt moi j'ai le savoir
ont d'abord je sais pas si je vais
attendre et voir mais j'adore les
costumes j'adore sujet j'adore
l'histoire
j'apprends que plus à moitié m'a pris
les choses personne
- ce qui je m'en fous je venu dans la
bible d'autres gens qui méritent
polanski en taule qu'est-ce que qu'est
ce que vous entendez du footeux côté
j'en sortais perdre et c'est important
on s'est dit on peut pas parler qu'on
est dessus
[Applaudissements]
on va donner la parole à quelqu'un qui
va calmer les esprits qui va dire
quelque chose d'autre ce fut
certainement fabien alors d'abord aller
voir ce film pour moi c'est un acte
politique
oui quel con parce que d'abord le viol
c'est un crime non mais c'est un crime
qui reste aujourd'hui afin plusieurs
crimes qui restent impunis d'où sortez
vous sur facebook ici pour moi en année
la série mercy scellé par cette envolée
chypre aux biens politique très
important d'avoir ou pas le fait de
pendentifs et je pense que trente cinq
millions de femmes qui nous regardent en
france qui sont femmes solidaires que
celle de ce crime impuni
ces crimes impunis chacun découvre le
moment il n'y a pas eu de procès pour
les autres puissent et les rémois
j'attends qu'on change cette loi
oui oui mais c'est les millions de
personnes avaient besoin d'être présent
le crime
on passe les poules se trouvait je
trouve cette subvention est pas toujours
les gens les ans pardon pardon isabelle
les gens qui osent dire comme isabelle
j'y vais parce qu'à une côte qui est
importante c'est l'antisémitisme
c'est par un jeune prévenu des conneries
mais à ce point c'est quand même quelque
chose ou deuxième conneries qui mise à
bas des acteurs qu'on joueurs faut
respecter les acteurs exemple difficile
mais c'est pas toi qui n'est pas très
méritoire alors tous les quatre ans
calais ni toi on a digéré que moi je dis
elle extrêmement bien résumé tout à
l'heure géraldine pardon vous allez en
allant voir ce film pardon vous allez
voir le film d'une personne qu'il faut
aujourd'hui qui a été condamné pour des
propos du même pas les redire tellement
essayé mon les propos qu'a dit
effectivement géraldine maillet aller
voir ce film c'est quelque part l'excusé
attendu désormais entendre christophe
carrière qui revient en plus ce qui
vient du public merci alors christophe
vitoux alors je suis même plus par où
commencer vous dit à part le délai non
voudra mais pourquoi vous allez gagner
c'est tout il faut parvenir soit que je
vais y aller parce que le mec en fait
effectivement été condamnant 77 mais
depuis il ya dix personnes qui
l'accusent de viol y a pas eu de
poursuites
il n'y a même pas eu de plainte va pas
c'est de dire attendez de voir les
dossiers qui vont être montés à décharge
donc c'est incroyable tribunal
médiatique maintenant je dis pas qu'il
n'a rien fait et j'écoute la parole des
femmes qui se plaignent mais c'est
dingue comme maintenant un homme est
jugé sur bénéteau sociaux sinon ils
seront pas pourquoi on n'a pas le temps
on est on a empanné chose j'aimerais
qu'on ait les chiffres pour les
téléspectateurs et les chips et
s'implique sur la première séance par
issa carter paris intra muros il a fait
5000 entrées c'est un carton de passer
le million d'entrées a minima le carton
voilà je vous le dit un mot que la
promotion est tout ce qu'il ya eu autour
de ce film a fait une promo incroyable
pour le film puisque ces affaires un
énorme carton
c'est le deuxième meilleur démarrage de
la carrière de romane polanski voilà
donc je vous dis le film va être un
énorme carton à voir ce qu'en pensent
les téléspectateurs voient là à regarder
s'il vous plaît en régie non c'est là
c'est la fiche merci voilà et on va on
va voir oui ou non est ce que vous allez
aller voir le film qui a gagné ce soir
le oui ou le non en tout cas merci
d'avoir des battus parce que vous avez
été très fort même si y en a qui se sont
levés qu'ils sont partis qui sont venus
c'est ce qu'on aime les cherry on veut
on peut avoir les résultats on les aura
demain merci apparemment à bord les a
donc voilà oui à 43%
c'est maintenant le seul à 57,61 c'est
le nom qu'a gagné un petit peu ce qui se
passe ici regardez 6 4